Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass, diesmal mit einem ungewöhnlichen Moderator und einem noch ungewöhnlicheren Gast, der heute seinen Gästigdebüt feiern darf. Wer das ist, hört ihr jetzt im Kurzpass. Herzlich willkommen zu Kurzpass Nummer 148, glaube ich es ist. Mein Name ist Frank Helmschuh und ich bin der Ed Helmi über Twitter und ich bin heute euer Moderator. Mein Gast ist heute, naja zum ersten Mal als Gast im Rasenfunk, wenn man es streng nimmt, aber seine Stimme, die kennt ihr. Ich begrüße ganz herzlich Max Jakob Ost.
Hi Frank und ich muss sagen, Props daran, dass du, obwohl ich das Intro runter und hochgezogen habe in der Lautstärke, dass du so gut da das Timing hingekriegt hast. Ich habe es ein Stückchen zu spät runtergezogen, das war mein Fehler, dass du da über dem Schlagzeug schon warst.
Aber ich will trotzdem mit einem klassikeren Sportjournalismus einsteigen, Max. Wie fühlt sich das auf der anderen Seite?
Da ich weiter noch die Sendung fahre, ehrlich gesagt, so wie immer.
Okay, dann lass uns vielleicht lieber zum Thema kommen. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, viele von euch oder die meisten von euch haben sicherlich mitbekommen, da Max war in den letzten Monaten fast schon Jahren, kann man mittlerweile sagen, auf jeden Fall über einem Jahr. Neben dem Rasenfunk auch noch mit einem anderen Projekt befasst, beschäftigt. Und der Rasenfunk hat er mir am Anfang gesagt, muss darunter ein bisschen leiden. Wird da ein bisschen kürzer kommen, wenn ich ehrlich bin? Ich glaube, so richtig viel kürzer gekommen ist er gar nicht, weil da Max ein Arbeitstier ist. Aber heute können wir endlich mal darüber sprechen, um was es da geht. Es hat Fußballbezug, es hat keinen direkten Bezug zum Rasenfunk. Aber wir wollten einfach mal die Gelegenheit nutzen, heute mal ein bisschen darüber zu sprechen. Max, erzähl uns doch mal, was ist das für ein Projekt und was handelt es sich da?
Völlig verrückte Situation, dass ich das jetzt noch mal pitchen muss, obwohl wir zwei ja schon seit, ich glaube, ich habe dir schon vor zwei Jahren davon erzählt.
Ja, das könnte hinkommen.
Ja, so alt ist ja auch die Idee schon. Es gibt einen neuen Podcast, der ab heute scheint auf allen Plattformen, der heißt 11 Leben. Und in der ersten Staffel beschäftigt sich dieser Podcast mit der Biografie von Uli Hoeneß. Ich habe versucht oder versuche immer noch, die Welt von Uli Hoeneß nicht nur nachzuerzählen, sondern auch zu verstehen und mal ganz tief einzutauchen in diese Biografie, die halt meiner Meinung nach nicht nur als Person an sich Interessantes, sondern halt auch für den deutschen Fußball so eine große Rolle gespielt hat. Und das mache ich jetzt gerade und habe es die ganzen letzten Monate gemacht.
Das klingt tatsächlich nach einem Mammut-Projekt. Und ich weiß ja, dass es auch eins ist, immer noch. Man kann gar nicht sagen, war. Denn das Ganze ist quasi noch, auch wenn die ersten Folgen erscheinen, mitten drin sozusagen.
Genau, das ist auch tatsächlich ein bisschen so gewollt, weil wir durchaus die Reaktionen, die es auf dem Podcast gibt, nicht nur jetzt von Hörern und Hörern, sondern vielleicht gibt es ja auch noch andere Reaktionen mit einarbeiten wollen. Es hat allerdings auch damit zu tun, wie dieser Podcast gemacht ist. Also um die Entstehungsgeschichte vielleicht kurz zu erzählen. Du hörst es jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal, weil du warst ja live mit dabei, Frank. Aber Anfang 2018 gab es die Idee zu diesem Podcast, auch gleich als Idee, das als eigenen Podcast zu machen und in Kooperation mit jemandem anderen, da können wir ja gleich nochmal drüber sprechen. Und aus ganz verschiedenen Gründen, da kamen ganz viele Dinge zusammen, hat das jetzt zwei Jahre, über zwei Jahre gedauert, bis es tatsächlich zu diesem Podcast gekommen ist. Und mindestens das letzte Jahr ist aber auch mit intensivster Recherchearbeit verbunden gewesen, also ich habe, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, also ich hab's mir jetzt nicht nochmal irgendwie angeguckt, aber es dürfte eigentlich im letzten Jahr locker, im letzten Jahr keinen Tag gegeben haben, an dem ich nicht irgendetwas für dieses Projekt getan habe. Na gut, allerhöchstens mal einen Spieltag, wo ich dann nur für den Rasenfunk gearbeitet hab. Aber ansonsten, seitdem bin ich Hals über Kopf, ganz tief stecke ich in Archiven Bücher und Dokumentationen, die es über Uli Hoeneß gibt, habe ich sowieso auch natürlich alle gelesen, mehrfach, habe mir ganz viele Spiele angeguckt, noch mal gerade aus seiner Spielerzeit. Und bin da eben auch immer noch mit dabei. Also dieses Projekt ist immer noch nicht fertig. Das ist der Aspekt, der bei mir den Puls hochjagt, der es aber gleichzeitig auch reizvoll macht. Also klar wäre es schön als Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn man direkt gleich alle Folgen hätte. Ich habe aber so das Gefühl, dass ich durchaus noch mal etwas verändern könnte mit diesem Projekt jetzt, wo es dann öffentlich wird. Und deswegen war das von Anfang an unser Plan. Nein, das soll noch nicht abgeschlossen sein. Wir wollen quasi das, was jetzt dann vielleicht passiert, noch mit einarbeiten. Denn es geht ja unter anderem um die Frage, kriege ich denn vielleicht auch Uli Hoeneß für ein Interview zu diesem Podcast?
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage. Aber ich will noch mal ein paar Sekunden zurückspulen, weil du gerade mit dem Thema Recherche eingestiegen bist. Lass uns doch vielleicht mal kurz in den Trailer reinhören, weil der passt da so ein bisschen in den Kontext.
Stimmt, dann hören wir jetzt den Elfleben Trailer. Es werden fünf Bücher über mich geschrieben.
Alle diese Leute haben mit mir kein Wort gewechselt.
Kein Wort. Es wird nicht darum gehen, dass man informieren will.
Nein, man will Kohle verdienen.
Und das ist frevelhafter. Wenn ihr den Uli Hoeneß kennenlernen wollt, das habt ihr schon selbst geschafft. Und wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr es im Google nachschauen. Denn was anderes haben die, die die Bücher geschrieben haben, auch nicht gemacht. Na ja, ein bisschen mehr habe ich schon gemacht. Aber halt kein Buch. Hi, mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin Sportjournalist aus München. Und bisher kannte man mich vor allem aus meinem eigenen Fußball-Podcast, dem Rasenfunk. Aber die letzten zwei Jahre meines Lebens habe ich auch noch etwas anderem gewidmet. Und das könnt ihr alle jetzt endlich, endlich hören. Seit zwei Jahren beschäftige ich mich mit einer der faszinierendsten Persönlichkeiten des deutschen Fußballs, Uli Hoeneß. Manche lieben ihn, manche hassen ihn. Und ich? Tja, keine Ahnung. Ich habe noch keine abgeschlossene Meinung zu ihm. Und manchmal glaube ich, damit bin ich der einzige in Deutschland. Genau das ist der Grund, warum ich diesen Podcast unbedingt machen wollte. Und die Idee auch nicht abfallen lassen, als das ganze Projekt schon kurz vor dem Ausstand. Ich bin in das Leben von Uli Hoeneß eingetaucht und nehme euch mit in seine Welt. Und nein, ich habe nicht nur gegoogelt. Ich habe Bücher gelesen, Dokumentationen gesehen, mehr Zeit in Zeitungsarchiven verbracht als an der frischen Luft und in ganz Deutschland Interviews geführt. Aus einer fixen Idee wurde so das Projekt meines Lebens. Gemeinsam werden wir nicht nur die Geschichte von Uli Hoeneß, sondern auch die des deutschen Fußballs aufarbeiten. Und ihr könnt mir dabei zuhören, wie ich versuche, eine Antwort auf die Frage zu bekommen. Kann denn irgend so ein Podcaster aus München überhaupt mit Uli Hoeneß sprechen, wenn er denn will? Kriege ich ihn für ein Interview? Ab dem 9. September könnt ihr die ersten Folgen hören. Auf Audio Now und überall, wo es Podcasts gibt. Es wird spannend, versprochen.
Ja, jetzt haben wir deine Stimme gehört. Es war fast ein bisschen komisch, dich vorher zu hören und dich jetzt noch mal im Trailer zu hören. Aber ja, also um es auch nochmal auf den Punkt zu bringen, du hast es ja vorhin schon gesagt, du hast nicht nur gegoogelt und auch mehr als ein paar dieser zitierten fünf Bilder, Entschuldigung, fünf Bücher gelesen. Der Aufwand war da schon enorm. Was würdest du denn heute sagen, hat dir so den den meisten Aufwand bereitet oder vielleicht auch so ein bisschen den meisten Erkenntnis gewinnt? Also in welchen Bereichen sind dir Dinge begegnet, die dir so komplett neu waren?
Also tatsächlich in der Archivrecherche, dann auf Einzelartikelebene. Also kleines Beispiel, also ich bin in mehreren aktiven Archiven ganz genau unterwegs. Wir haben auch ganz, ganz viel Material zusammengestellt bekommen von dem Partner, mit dem das veröffentlicht wird. Also das waren allein, glaube ich, 500 oder 600 PDF-Seiten. Einfach alles, Interviews und Artikel über Uli Hoeneß. Da kriegt man natürlich schon mal viel mit, was man vielleicht auch noch gar nicht wusste. Aber tatsächlich, was mir so in der Arbeit dann ein bisschen auch in Teilen die Augen geöffnet hat, war, ins Kicker-Archiv zu steigen, den einfach nach Hoeneß zu suchen und dann alles zu lesen, was da kommt. Also das ist quasi das, was ich auch immer noch mache. Ich gebe Hoeneß ein und dann das Ja. Und da beginnst du halt irgendwann mit 1969, 1970, ab dann war er bei den Bayern. Und dann guckst du dir halt einfach jeden Artikel kurz an. Und ganz oft sind das dann natürlich auch nur Spielberichte. Und irgendwann kommt dann auch noch Dieter Hoeneß ins Spiel. Dann hast du auch noch so ein bisschen, ja gut, den Hoeneß hab ich nicht gesucht. Also immer wenn VfB im Kontext ist, dann nee, brauch ich jetzt nicht. Aber tatsächlich, da habe ich ganz viele Sachen über den deutschen Fußball gelernt, die ich auch so noch nicht vorher immer gelesen hatte. Also ich bin ja schon tiefer in der Geschichte der Bundesliga-Historie drin oder dachte zumindest, ich wäre es drin, hab schon mehrere Bücher drüber gelesen. Aber ich hab dann auch immer wieder durch die Ausgaben durchgeblättert, um eben Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was war denn im Jahr 1972 wichtig? Wie hat man denn damals über die Europameisterschaft gedacht? Wie war die Bundesliga? Und da habe ich ganz viele kleinere Entwicklungen gefunden, die mir so neu waren, auch so ganz viel zur, eigentlich auch viel auch zu Finanzdingen, was die Bundesliga angeht, wie sich Bundesliga-Vereine früher finanziert haben. Da hatte ich schon so ein grobes Vorwissen, aber da habe ich am meisten dazugelernt, muss ich sagen. Und das fließt dann auch in den Podcast ein.
Jetzt hast du ja eben schon den Partner erwähnt, ohne seinen Namen zu nennen. An dem Trailer haben wir bereits Audio Now als Veröffentlichungsplattform gehört. Erzähl uns doch mal ein bisschen was darüber.
Genau, also für den Podcast heißt das für sich genommen jetzt eigentlich erst mal gar nichts, weil er ist überall frei verfügbar. Da stehen wir zwei ja auch für. Und logischerweise habe ich da auch bei diesem Projekt darauf geachtet. Also es gibt keine Paywall hinter der man das hören kann. Mit einer ganz kleinen Einschränkung. Die allerersten drei Folgen werden zeitgleich auf Audio Now und in deren App veröffentlicht. Das ist eine kostenlose und wahlfreie App. Und wöchentlich dann auf allen anderen Plattformen Abfolge 4 erscheinen. Aber die folgen immer überall gleichzeitig. Warum das so ist, kann ich vielleicht auch gleich nochmal kurz erzählen. Der Partner ist die Audio Alliance. Das ist die, nennen wir es einfach den Audiobereich von Bertelsmann. Und die stecken auch hinter Audio Now, die sie als eigene Podcast-Plattform etabliert haben. Mit eigenen explosiven Formaten, aber auch vielen anderen Formaten. Aber bisher auch werbefrei und ein bisschen anders gestaltet als so manch andere Podcast-Plattform. Also ich glaube, manche haben da jetzt schon aufgehäuft, aber schaut euch Audio Now an. Und die Bedingungen, ich hatte eben klare Vorstellungen, unter welchen Umständen ich dieses Projekt umsetzen würde. Es war klar, dass es nicht alleine geht, weil ihr habt es ja auch schon im Trailer gehört, da ist Musik involviert, das es professionell produziert. Da steckt ja natürlich auch ein gewisses Risiko dahinter. Ein solches Projekt anzugehen, das war klar, das kann jetzt nicht als Rasenfunk 2 laufen. Und wir machen das genauso wie immer. Deswegen war klar, es braucht einen Partner. Und da war aber mir ganz wichtig, dass es jemand ist, der das dann aber auch allen zur Verfügung stellt, der das dann auch dafür dann mir bezahlt. Also es ist quasi eine Auftragsarbeit. Und das kann aber jeder hören. Ich wollte unbedingt, dass es nicht hinter einer Paywall liegt oder so, weil wir zwei, wir haben eine klare Haltung zu Paywalls.
Genau, und da haben wir ja tatsächlich auch relativ früh darüber gesprochen. Und das habe ich ja dann auch mitbekommen, wie, ähm, welch große Rolle das im Grunde auch bei der Suche nach einem Partner und bei den Gesprächen geführt hat, gespielt hat, wollte ich sagen. Genau. Und jetzt hattest du vorhin, da ist mir noch was eingefallen, du hattest gerade erwähnt, die du suchst in den Archiven nach den nach Hoeneß und den Jahreszahlen. Können wir denn bei dem Podcast mit einer chronologischen Abfolge rechnen? Oder wie baut sich der auf? Was werden wir denn in den ersten drei Folgen hören?
Also es gibt zwei Handlungsstränge in dem Projekt, in den einzelnen Folgen. Und der eine und wichtige Handlungsstrang ist das Leben von Uli Hoeneß in chronologischer Reihenfolge. Also wir beginnen in Folge eins. Da beginnen wir in Ulm, wo er aufgewachsen ist. Ich habe mich mit Sandkastenfreunden von ihm getroffen, mit seinem alten Sportlehrer getroffen, mit denen Interviews geführt und in der ersten Folge arbeiten wir dann zum Beispiel seine Jugend in Ulm auf. Und in der zweiten Folge dann sind wir dann schon beim FC Bayern. Und es geht dann um die Anfangszeit bei Bayern bis hin zur WM und in Folge drei dann einfach weiter, also bis dann zum Karriereende als Spieler und irgendwann wird er dann Manager. Das heißt, da arbeiten wir uns chronologisch vor, was, glaube ich, auch ganz gut für die Verständlichkeit ist und was vor allem hilft. Also das ist schon interessant, dass man immer wieder Muster in Leben von Menschen erkennt. Wahrscheinlich wäre es so, wenn wir dein Leben aufarbeiten würden oder meins, dann wäre es ähnlich, dass man Dinge entdeckt, die wir irgendwann in unseren 20er Jahren gemacht haben, wo man sagt, ach, ist sehr interessant. Später war er ja ganz genauso oder ach, später hat er sich nochmal verändert und hat das anders gemacht. Das finde ich interessant. Also es baut alles aufeinander auf. Und der zweite Handlungsstrang, das ist dann tatsächlich ein bisschen ein Blick hinter die Kulissen des Podcasts. Das wird ja auch im Trailer angedeutet. Es war nicht so, dass das jetzt alles so einfach durchlief, von der Idee bis zur Veröffentlichung, sondern das ganze Projekt war schon einmal im Grunde schon vorbei. Und dann ist es durch glückliche Umstände doch wieder aufgenommen worden. Das erzähle ich ein bisschen, wie ich die Arbeit am Projekt angegangen bin. Und natürlich haben wir auch Uli Hoeneß angefragt. Ich habe versucht, an Uli Hoeneß heranzukommen. Und dabei kann man mir auch zuhören.
Wir werden natürlich jetzt nicht darüber sprechen können, ob du ihn bekommen hast oder nicht. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass allein die Tatsache ihn anzufragen, wenn ich dich, also ich kenne dich ja schon eine Weile. Und ich kenne dich ja auch aus einer Zeit, in der dein Fußballherz noch heiß gebrannt hat. Für den FC Bayern und auch eben als jemanden, der den Uli Hoeneß quasi sein Leben lang irgendwie begleitet hat, fußballerisch. Das war mit Sicherheit allein schon aufregend, überhaupt anzufragen, oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht, Frank. Also ehrlich gesagt, also die Anfrage...
Sind die Flammen schon so stark?
Nee, na doch, also vielleicht schon. Also das ist natürlich auch Teil des Podcasts, dass ich ja inzwischen dem ganzen Fußballgeschäft und auch dem FC Bayern kritischer gegenüberstehe als noch vor zehn Jahren. Wie sollte es auch anders sein, möchte man fast sagen. Nee, ehrlich gesagt fand ich den Moment der Anfrage dann selbst, das unterscheidet sich dann nur in der Form von anderen Anfragen, die ich schon abgeschickt habe. Also dann ist es tatsächlich... Also die Entstehung und wie das alles, wie wir da vorgegangen sind, das kann man auch dann alles noch hören. Das ist schon ein bisschen anders, als es jetzt bei Anfragen für Tribünengespräche zum Beispiel so läuft beim Rasenfunk. Aber dann ist es im Grunde eine ähnliche Geschichte, die man erzählen muss. Man muss sagen, wer bin ich? Was mache ich sonst so? Warum hätte ich gerne ein Gespräch mit Ihnen? Und das hat sich dann... Also in der Sache an sich war das dann eigentlich... Also ich habe mich sehr schwer getan, aber das lag eher daran, dass es halt nichts Alltägliches ist. Aber ich war jetzt nicht irgendwie da besonders emotional involviert, weil es Uli Hoeneß ist, zu dem ich früher mal halt ein Verhältnis als Fan hatte. Ich glaube, das hat da eher weniger eine Rolle gespielt.
Max, du hast ja mit ziemlich vielen Menschen gesprochen. Im Trailer war es ja auch zu hören, Quer durch Deutschland, so ein bisschen Gefahren für Interviews. Gibt es da so einen Interview-Partner, der dir so auf eine besondere Art und Weise geblieben ist bei den Dingen, die bisher produziert sind?
Ja, ich würde sagen zwei. Also es sind auch zwei der prominentesten Namen. Also ich möchte jetzt nicht damit andeuten, dass ich damit jetzt noch mit 100 anderen in dieser Kategorie gesprochen hätte. Aber sowohl das Gespräch mit Willy Lemke als auch das mit Christoph Daum waren sehr interessante. Und waren ehrlich gesagt auch beides Gespräche, wo ich mir gedacht habe, also gut, das hat jetzt leider den Makel, dass es immer nur um Uli Hoeneß geht oder um den Bezug zu Uli Hoeneß. Und zum deutschen Fußball. Aber das wären auch hervorragende Tribünengespräche gewesen. Also gerade mit Christoph Daum, das wäre eigentlich, das habe ich ihm dann auch danach gesagt, also Herr Daum, vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit. Wenn Sie Lust haben, da nochmal zwei Stunden draufzulegen, dann machen wir das nochmal und reden über Sie. Weil das waren einfach schon, das sind Menschen, mit denen kannst du dich gut unterhalten. Beide auch grundverschieden, aber es waren beides sehr interessante Interviews, auch fordernd für mich als Fragesteller, das muss man schon auch sagen. Und es kamen aber interessante Gespräche dabei raus. Und du hast wieder gesehen, dass dieses Prinzip Rasenfunk, nenne ich es jetzt einfach, was total arrogant ist, weil es hat eigentlich jetzt nichts mit dem Rasenfunk zu tun, aber quasi sich für ein Gespräch Zeit zu nehmen und gut vorbereitet dahin zu fahren und dann auch mal in die Tiefe zu gehen und dem Gesprächspartner auch mal drei Minuten für seine Antwort zu geben oder fünf Minuten, völlig egal. Und das war genau wie bei den Tribünengesprächen, das auch häufig zu beobachten ist. Man merkt, dass sich die Gesprächspartner entspannen, wenn sie es merken, A, da ist jemand vorbereitet, B, ich kann jetzt auch mal meinen Gedanken zu Ende führen, kann auch noch neuen Gedanken anschließen, ich werde nicht sofort unterbrochen. Es wird eine andere Art von Gespräch draus. Und dann mit Leuten zu sprechen, die so lange im Fußballgeschäft sind, die logischerweise ihren ganz eigenen Blick auf die Bundesliga, auf Vereine, auf den Fußball als solches haben. Das ist schon einfach erst mal sehr interessant. Und da sind wirklich gute Gespräche rausgekommen. Und die größten Schmerzen habe ich jetzt, wenn ich dann die Zitatschnipsel auswählen muss, die ich dann aus diesen Gesprächen rausnehme. Du kennst mich. Hätte ich natürlich am liebsten, okay, also jetzt hören wir mal eine halbe Stunde das und dann eine halbe Stunde das. Geht aber halt dann in so einem Format schwierig. Nee, ja gut, doch von der Tiefe eigentlich schon. Aber es wird eher getragen, also es ist alles sehr viel dichter. Es sind Tribünengespräche komprimiert auf weniger Zeit. Zumindest ist das mein Eindruck. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das sich dann auch mit dem der Hörerinnen und Hörer deckt. Aber es ist jetzt ein Podcast, den würde ich persönlich, obwohl ich ja alles auf erhöhte Geschwindigkeit höre, würde ich den nicht auf erhöhte Geschwindigkeit hören, weil dann gehen, glaube ich, Informationsschnipsel verloren, weil ich schon wirklich ganz, ganz viel da reinpresse und noch viel mehr musste ich weglassen. Das heißt, es sind Tribünengespräche ohne die Luft dazwischen.
Ja, genau, ich habe das tatsächlich auch auf den Interviewpartner bezogen. Also man kann halt einfach nicht in so einem Format jemanden dann an einer Antwort fünf Minuten ausformulieren lassen. Das passt dann halt am Ende nicht ins Format. In der Gänze kann ich dem nur beipflichten, ich hatte ja die Ehre, schon mal früh in eine Vorabversion einer Folge reinzuhören. Ich bin zwar niemand, der Podcasts mit größerer Geschwindigkeit hört, so grundsätzlich, aber ich kann es gut nachvollziehen, dass du sagst, das ginge tatsächlich bei diesem Podcast schwer, weil die Informationsdichte ist wahnsinnig groß. Und ich habe bei mir gemerkt, ich bin jemand, der Podcasts grundsätzlich nebenbei hört, beim Putzen, beim Kochen. Beim Autofahren ist vielleicht die Konzentrationsmöglichkeit auf dem Podcast noch am größten. Aber als ich da mal reingehört habe, ging es mir schnell so, dass ich gemerkt habe, wenn ich nicht hundertprozentig bei der Sache bin, dann verliere ich den Faden. Und ich glaube, das spricht für die Informationstiefe.
Ja, vielleicht rede ich auch manchmal nur ein bisschen zu schnell. Das war für mich natürlich auch eine große Umstellung im Rasenfunk, immer so vor sich hin plappern. Wir unterhalten uns jetzt gerade sehr entspannt. Ich stehe hier wie immer an meinem Schreibtisch, habe meinen Kaffee neben mir. Bei 11 Leben ist es ein Skript, das ich vorher in unzähligen Stunden geschrieben habe, das vorher schon ganz viele Stadien durchlaufen hat und das dann von mir an irgendeinem Punkt eingesprochen werden musste. Und das ist nochmal etwas komplett anderes, sowohl vom Hören als auch vom Sprechen, als es der Rasenfunk ist. Nicht dieses Sprechen der Denken, sondern das im Grunde nach Erzählen eines vorformulierten Gedanken, aber du willst ihn dann so erzählen, dass die Leute trotzdem zuhören. Vielleicht hört man auch an der einen oder anderen Stelle, dass ich da kein Profisprecher bin. Aber damit müssen wir alle leben. Und vielleicht macht es das auch, ehrlich gesagt, authentischer. Also es ist schon immer noch der Max, der das spricht. Aber vom Arbeiten her eine ganz neue Erfahrung für mich. Und unter anderem deshalb wollte ich auch dieses Projekt dann unbedingt machen, weil ich sowas einfach mal machen wollte. Ich höre solche Podcasts so gerne. Ich liebe solche Podcast-Formate. Und jetzt habe ich mich mal selber an einem versucht, oder versuche mich ja immer noch an einem. Und ja, danach habe ich da einen Haken hinter und mache erst mal Pause. Beziehungsweise ein paar Tribünengespräche.
Ja, auf die Pause möchte ich gleich noch mal eingehen. Ich kenne dich ja, wie gesagt, ein bisschen. Und ich weiß, spätestens, wenn alle Folgen draußen sind, wirst du irgendwann da selber durchhören. Wirst dir die Dinge notieren, die dir nicht gefallen. Und so hast du es beim Rasenfunk gemacht ab der ersten Sendung. Das ist der Grund, warum der Max heute ganz schlecht die frühen Sendungen hören kann. Und so wirst du es wahrscheinlich hier machen. Aber im Gegensatz zum Rasenfunk, bei dem du es nächste Woche einfach besser machen kannst, braucht es hier ja ein neues Projekt, um es beim nächsten Mal besser zu machen. Jetzt natürlich, um Gottes Willen, weiß keiner, was kommt. Aber mal so aus der ersten Erfahrung, jetzt ist das Ding gerade mal veröffentlicht und noch nicht ganz fertig, wie wir schon mehrfach erwähnt haben. Aber so aus deiner Erfahrung dieses gesamten Arbeitens, würdest du sagen, ich hab da Gefallen dran gefunden, es war stressig und es war aufwendig, aber es ist insgesamt doch eine coole Sache, oder sagst du, um Gottes Willen, also es war gut, das mal gemacht zu haben, jetzt hab ich's erfahren, aber es war mir doch ein bisschen too much.
Ganz schwierige Frage für mich.
Dafür bin ich bekannt, hier, schwierige Fragen.
Genau, und du stellst auch Fragen, anders als ich, der oft einfach nur Sachen sagt und die Gäste dann völlig allein lässt im Luftleerenraum. Also, dieses Projekt macht mir unheimlich Spaß. Und vor allem, also ich hoffe, dass ich da nichts übersehe, aber mir persönlich ist kein anderes solches Projekt im deutschsprachigen Podcastraum bekannt, was einfach in dieser Art und Weise die Biografie eines Menschen aufarbeitet. Ich hoffe, dass ich da nichts Wichtiges übersehen habe. Ich finde auch, dass es in den USA gibt es vielleicht zwei, drei Formate, die ähnlich in die Richtung kommen. Ich persönlich hatte sehr großen Gefallen an Making Obama von WNBC Chicago, die seine Biografie aufgearbeitet haben, bis hin zu dem Moment, in dem er Präsident wurde. Und das hat mir sehr gut gefallen. Und die haben das auch ein bisschen ähnlich gemacht. Ich habe mich jetzt logischerweise nicht voll an den orientiert oder so. Aber an diesem Podcast musste ich immer wieder denken. Da wurde viel mit Weggefährten gesprochen. Barack Obama war selbst Gesprächspartner. Und dann wurde einfach nacherzählt, wie seine politische Karriere aussah. Ein bisschen zu verliebt vielleicht manchmal an der einen oder anderen Stelle, weil er ja auch ein Sohn Chicagos ist und die ihn deswegen ganz toll finden. Und Barack Obama ja generell einen ganz guten Leum und Tat. Aber von der Art und Weise fand ich das unglaublich spannend. Und diesen Podcast, den habe ich auch im Rasenfunk definitiv mal empfohlen. Die zweite Staffel ging dann um Beyoncé. Den habe ich immer wieder so im Kopf mitgetragen. Und das zu machen, das macht unheimlich Spaß. Und das könnte ich mir so gut vorstellen. Es hängt allerdings schon auch davon ab, ob das jetzt nur mir Spaß macht oder ob das auch anderen Spaß macht. Also wenn wir jetzt feststellen, andere Leute finden das in Teilen gut und hören das sehr gerne, dann lohnt auch der unglaubliche Aufwand, der dahinter steht. Sollte sich jetzt aber rausstellen, so tief wollte dann doch keiner in den deutschen Fußball eintauchen, dann steht das glaube ich weniger in einem Verhältnis, wo es für mich zu rechtfertigen ist. Weil der Aufwand hat schon... Also jetzt für diese Staffel... Also so könnte man jetzt die nächste Staffel nicht nochmal machen. Also das war ja mehr als ein Jahr Arbeit eigentlich. Und jeden Tag und ganz viele Stunden. Und das ist dann tatsächlich zu viel, zumindest für eine Person. Vielleicht müsste man da dann darüber nachdenken, wie man das irgendwie anders machen kann. Aber ich meine, da bin ich ja auch bekannt dafür. Also da bin ich ja auch selber dran schuld, dass ich mich dann immer so reinfuchse. Und ich habe halt das Problem gehabt bei der Recherche. Man sollte ja meinen, wenn man fünf Biografien zu jemandem gelesen hat und dann noch ein paar Dokus gesehen hat und ganz viele Interviews und so weiter gelesen hat, dass man dann viele Fragen beantwortet hat. Und bei mir war es aber dann so, dass sich eher immer wieder neue Fragen aufgeworfen haben. Und dann auch ganz oft Fragen, die gar nicht mehr primär mit Uli Hoeneß zu tun hatten, sondern mit dem deutschen Fußball. Also dann stehe ich eben auf einmal vor der Frage, okay, welche Auswirkungen hatte denn der Bundesliga-Skandal in 1971 konkret auf die Vereine? Okay, was hat sich denn damit verändert, dass dann Trikotsponsoren eingeführt wurden? Wie hat das die Finanzierung von Bundesliga-Vereinen verändert? Ach, welche Rolle haben eigentlich Stadien gespielt beim Einnahmenmix von Bundesligisten damals? Ach, dann kamen ja auf einmal Uerdingen und Leverkusen mit einem großen Pharmakonzern dahinter in die Liga und gleichzeitig wurden die zwei Zweiteligen zu einer Liga zusammengelegt. Da gingen ja ganz viele Plätze im Profifußball verloren. Es ist ja klar, dass das ein totales Hauen und Stechen war, weißt du so? Und dann kommst du von Detail zu Detail. Ja, wirklich, wirklich. Und ich bin halt auch wirklich schlecht da drin, an Hasenlöchern vorbeizugehen. Also ich muss da zumindest dann kurz die Nase reinstecken. Und das ist das, was es dann neben der eben im Archiv alle Artikel lesen, was natürlich auch ein bisschen, also, ich meine, das sind ein paar tausend Artikel jetzt bisher schon gewesen, die ich gelesen habe. Das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen bekloppt, muss man schon auch sagen. Aber das ist es, was es so tiefgehend gemacht hat. Und das ist dann schon vielleicht in Summe ein bisschen viel gewesen. Aber ich kann da halt leider auch nicht aus meiner Haut raus. Ich muss dann da immer, weiß ich, bestellen wir da noch ein Buch und noch ein Buch. Dann lese ich hier noch einen Artikel und naja.
Wie schwer fällt es dir denn, da die Grenzen zu setzen für den Inhalt? Ich meine, diese Rabbit-Holes, diesen Hasenbau abzusteigen, gedanklich und in der Recherche, ist ja schön und recht, aber wie schwer fällt es dir denn, da dann abzugrenzen danach und zu sagen, okay, das muss ich jetzt irgendwie doch mit reinbringen, weil es für den Kontext wichtig ist und das andere eher nicht?
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, mein Gefühl, wenn ich am Skript sitze, dann dadurch, dass ich auch viele solche Podcasts, also so Storytelling nennt man das ja, also Geschichten erzählen der Formate oder ja auch Hörbücher und so weiter schon konsumiert habe, dann hat man so ein bisschen ein Gefühl dafür, wann muss jetzt wieder so grob eine Musik kommen oder ein O-Ton und wann wird es jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu tiefgehend. Und ich entscheide das dann quasi immer im Moment des Schreibens und ich muss aber halt ganz harte Entscheidungen treffen. Also ich muss viele Dinge weglassen und der entscheidende Faktor bei diesem Projekt ist dann natürlich immer, welchen Bezug hat das, was ich erzählen möchte, noch zu Uli Hoeneß und zum FC Bayern. Und da darf ich natürlich nie zu weit weg, auch wenn gerade da manchmal noch Geschichten am Wegesrand liegen, wo man sich denkt, ach man, was will ich so gerne noch erzählen. Ja, wirklich. Also ja, auch zu ganz vielen anderen Vereinen, zu anderen Persönlichkeiten des Fußballs. Aber im Grunde muss ich das dann aus dem Bauch heraus entscheiden. Und ich hoffe aber, dass es so geworden ist, das können aber nur die Hörerinnen und Hörer sagen, dass man sich diesen Podcast auch sehr gut anhören kann, wenn man nicht der die Hard FC Bayern Fan ist und vielleicht auch eher ein kritisches Verhältnis zu Uli Hoeneß hat. Ich glaube, man wird definitiv neue Dinge über Uli Hoeneß erfahren. Da bin ich mir ganz sicher, weil ich auch Sachen noch mal anders erzähle, als sie in den Biografien erzählt werden. Und ein paar Dinge sind meiner Meinung nach auch, also jetzt keine weltbewegenden Dinge, aber so kleine Details, die ich wichtig fand, die habe ich jetzt in den Biografien zum Beispiel nicht gelesen. Und man wird aber auch, glaube ich, wirklich noch mal einen anderen Blick auf den deutschen Fußball haben. Und ich hoffe, dass das dann der Mehrwert ist für alle Leute und vielleicht sogar auch für Leute, die sich gar nicht so viel für Fußball interessieren, weil man kann auch ganz gut nachvollziehen, wie das eigentlich so klappen konnte, dass der Fußball jetzt dieses allumfassende Gesellschaftsding ist und quasi in Bundespressekonferenzen im Nebensatz auch erwähnt wird, dass jetzt Bundesligaspiele stattfinden dürfen, aber nur noch als Geisterspiele und so weiter. Also wo quasi die Bedeutung des Fußballs herkommt. Ich glaube, das kriegt man auch ganz gut mit.
Ja, da bin ich sicher. Es geht ja tatsächlich auch wirklich um das Leben von Uli Hoeneß und um das noch mal aufzugreifen, weil ich glaube, die Frage stellen sich einige der Hörerinnen und Hörer. Du hast ganz am Anfang schon davon gesprochen, der Podcast heißt 11 Leben. Die erste Staffel dreht sich um Uli Hoeneß. Ich habe da ja vorhin versucht, ein bisschen hinzuleiten, wie es dir gefallen hat und ob dir du so was in Zukunft noch mal vorstellen kannst. Aber um die Frage der Sicherheit halber zu beantworten, eine zweite Staffel ist noch nicht geplant.
Es ist noch nichts Konkretes geplant. Wir machen jetzt, jetzt muss erst mal Staffel 1 fertig werden. Das war auch gar nicht immer so geplant, dass es auf Staffeln hin ausgelegt wird. Da kann man jetzt noch nichts zu sagen. Und weil wir jetzt hier im Rasenfunk sind, kann ich da dann auch ganz offen darüber sagen, das hängt auch für mich mit der Frage zusammen, hat jetzt vielleicht nicht der Rasenfunk doch ein bisschen unter dem Projekt. Ich habe immer versucht, das rauszuhalten, aber es gab ja ab einem Zeitpunkt, das haben wir ja auch angekündigt, keine Tribüngespräche mehr, außer es ist irgendwie was ganz Dringendes dann vor die Füße gefallen, also Schmerzmittel und Kaiserslautern haben wir, glaube ich, noch gemacht. Ach und die Fußballmagazine, also na gut, waren dann doch immerhin drei. Gut und dann noch das Triple, das Triple war ein Tribüngespräch, aber da habe ich ja, glaube ich, in irgendeiner Sendung gesagt, wenn die das Triple holen, muss ich vielleicht doch noch mal was dazu machen. Da bin ich ja selber dann schon wieder. Okay, gut, also es gab dann doch ein paar Tribüngespräche, aber es sind halt schon auch Sachen liegen geblieben. Und die Kurzpässe zu den internationalen Ligen sind irgendwann zur Pause gekommen. Das hatte nicht alles mit 11 Leben zu tun, sondern Corona hat da auch eine ganz große Rolle gespielt. Also gerade in Zeiten von Corona auch an 11 Leben noch weiter zu arbeiten, da haben ja alle gemerkt, dass ich am Rande der Belastbarkeit war in manchen Phasen dieses Jahres. Und ich habe jetzt schon Lust, jetzt dann erstmal im Rasenfunk wieder Sachen zu machen. Weil du weißt es ja auch, wie lang unsere Liste an Tribünengesprächen ist, wie weit ich auch bei manchen Tribünengesprächen schon in der Vorbereitung war. Jetzt haben sich noch neue Dinge ergeben, die gemacht werden könnten. Aber wenn es halt die Qualität haben soll, also zumindest die vermeintliche Qualität, also jetzt ist es einfach ganz subjektiv von mir, die wir zwei gerne hätten, dann muss ich da halt auch einfach sehr viel an Zeit rein investieren. Und die Zeit will ich mir jetzt eigentlich dann erstmal auch wieder nehmen. Vor allem ja auch wohl wissend, dass das Jahr 2021 termintechnisch auch für die Berichterstatterinnen und Berichterstatter im Fußball sehr anstrengend wird.
Aber ich würde sagen, vor allem lass uns jetzt erstmal den Fokus legen auf die Veröffentlichung von Staffel 1. Das ist ja tatsächlich das, was ab heute passiert, um es nochmal so ein bisschen rund zu machen. Ab heute, ich würde mal sagen auf allen Plattformen, also Podcasts, Feed, iTunes, Spotify und eben vor allem Audio Now. Bei Audio Now gibt es ab heute die ersten drei Folgen, bei allen anderen die erste Folge und dann jede Woche eine, bis sozusagen die ersten drei Wochen um sind. Und dann ab dann die vierte Folge auf einem Plattformen synchron.
Genau.
Max, gibt es irgendwas, was wir noch nicht besprochen haben? Was du gerne noch besprochen hättest?
Also vielleicht kann ich noch einmal ganz kurz erklären, warum es zu dieser, die ersten drei Folgen gibt, auf dem Plattform von Audio Now Lösung gekommen ist. Audio Now hat natürlich investiert in diesen Podcast, auch viel Vertrauen mir ehrlich gesagt geschenkt, dass das klappt. Es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass das Projekt, was so die geringste Aufmerksamkeit vielleicht bekommt, also allein der Name Uli Hoeneß, verpflichtet da glaube ich schon zu einigen Dingen. Und den Nutzen, den Audio Now daraus ziehen darf, ist natürlich neben dem, dass man, der Produzent dieses Podcasts ist oder ein bisschen der Absender, das ist ja ein Audio Now Original, ist eben auch aufmerksam zu machen auf die Plattform und die App, die man hat. Und so kam es dann zu dieser Lösung. Und ich finde das aber sehr bemerkenswert, ehrlich gesagt auch, zeigt, wie sehr die auch einfach verstanden haben, auch wie wir zicken, also ich nehme dich da jetzt einfach mit rein, für die bin ich ja auch quasi der Rasenfunk, also wir zwei, dass die dann auch sofort verstanden haben, dass man natürlich etwas machen kann, um jetzt zu sagen, hier, wenn euch das so sehr interessiert, dass ihr es gleich hören wollt, dann geht es auf unsere kostenlosen Plattformen, dass es aber auch sinnvoll ist, das zu sagen, okay, wir machen das jetzt am Anfang, und danach machen wir aber alles gleichzeitig auf allen Plattformen. Also so ein Modell, da kann ich mir jetzt auch gar nicht dran erinnern, dass das jemand schon gefahren hätte, und ich finde das super, weil ich finde das sehr, sehr fair. Und uns beiden ist ja immer Fairness am wichtigsten, Fairness gegenüber den Hörern und Hörern, und Fairness aber auch gegenüber demjenigen, der dann letztlich ja das ganze Ding bezahlt hat, und finde, das ist eine sehr schöne Lösung. Wer es unbedingt hören möchte, und dann aber auch warten muss, bis Folge 4 rauskommt, der kann das tun, der kann das kostenlos tun. Und das ist jetzt nicht mit großem Aufwand verbunden. Und alle anderen bekommen es dann aber so, wie es ja eigentlich heutzutage üblich ist bei Podcasts, dann wöchentlich zu hören. Und ab Folge 4 ist aber alles dann gleichzeitig auf allen Plattformen. Ich bin sehr froh, dass das so eine... Also ich finde, es ist eine hörerinnen- und hörerfreundliche Lösung. Und genau, so ist es dazu gekommen.
Genau, das finde ich tatsächlich auch. Ich glaube, nicht nur die freie Verfügbarkeit, sondern eben für Podcasts ist es meines Erachtens auch wichtig, dass man als Hörer oder Hörerin die Plattform selber wählen kann und damit die App. Ich merke selber, wie blöd das manchmal ist, wenn man so aus seinem gewohnten Podcatcher raus muss, weil es ist irgendein Ding. Mag die App okay sein, ich will gar nicht sagen, dass die eigene App immer die beste ist oder die, die man gerade nutzt. Aber man hat sich halt dran gewöhnt. Ich finde das gerade bei Podcasts das Schöne, dass man sich in den allermeisten Fällen die App aussuchen kann. Wenn dann irgendwas außerhalb stattfindet, dann ist es meistens ungewohnt und unangenehm und dann fehlt irgendein Feature, das man üblicherweise nutzt. Da ist es definitiv eine tolle Lösung, dass es überall verfügbar ist und eine wöchentliche Veröffentlichung ist ja durchaus üblich. Ich bin ja gern einer, der dann immer bis ans Ende des Veröffentlichungszyklus wartet, bevor er damit anfängt, weil ich dann doch gern lieber Binge-Listen sozusagen, also alles auf einmal höre. Aber das bleibt ja dann jedem selber überlassen und das ist tatsächlich das Entscheidende bei einer fairen Lösung. Jeder kann sich aussuchen, wann und wie er es gerne hören möchte.
Also ich bin ehrlich gesagt auch so, dass ich bis zum Schluss warte. Ich glaube allerdings, dass ihr dann gespoilert werdet, liebe Hörer und Auteur. Also in sozialen Netzwerken müsst ihr selber für euch entscheiden. Da gibt es durchaus ein paar Spoilerelemente in diesem Podcast. Es wird wahnsinnig aufregend, Frank.
Nicht zuletzt die Frage, was ist mit Uli Hoeneß?
Ja, Frank, ich meine, du weißt da ja auch schon mehr. Aber wir beide, wir sagen dazu... Vielleicht kann man aber noch eine Sache erzählen, die, glaube ich, dann noch interessant ist, weil das Umfeld des Rasenfunks auch dann schon an diesem Podcast mitgearbeitet hat. Dadurch, dass ich ja quasi der Absender und derjenige, der alles erstellt. Ruben Schulze-Fröhlich mit seiner Firma Wakeworld. Der produziert das, hat das Ganze, hat ein Team zusammengestellt, was mir ganz viel geholfen hat. Die Produktion des Podcasts, die technische Produktion, zum Beispiel, wird jetzt auch nicht von mir gemacht, sondern von dort, Musik wird dort gesucht und so weiter. Du hast mitgeholfen, Frank, nicht nur als emotionale Stütze, als alles vorbei war. Hab ich das? Natürlich. Darf ich dich mal kurz an unser Recherche-Forum erinnern, an das ich mich täglich einlogge? Also Frank hat uns quasi eine Möglichkeit, uns Recherchen zu bündeln, zur Verfügung gestellt. Und hast auch sehr viel emotionalen Support übergegeben an den verschiedenen emotionalen Tiefpunkten, die es da dann durchaus auch mal gab. Mani, der Manuel Kostrinski, at Disco Mani auf Twitter, der ja auch beim Rasenfunk das Logo gemacht hat und unsere Webseite designt hat. Der hat auch das Logo für ein 11 Leben designt, das Cover von 11 Leben. Stefan Rommel ist mit im inhaltlichen Team. Der hat mir bei der Recherche geholfen, ist euch ja auch aus dem Rasenfunk bekannt. Also sprich, es sind schon Rasenfunk-Vibes vorhanden bei diesem Projekt, würde ich mal sagen. Es kommt sogar eine kurze Stelle aus einer Schlusskonferenz vor. Weiß grad gar nicht, zu welcher Frage.
Das Projekt kann insgesamt den Rasenfunk nicht leugnen.
Nee, soll es ja auch nicht.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, ich glaube, dann haben wir wirklich alles durch, was man jetzt im Vorfeld sozusagen, wenn wir auch quasi gar nicht mehr so weit im Vorfeld sind, sondern schon am Start über das Projekt sagen kann. Ich kann von meiner Seite aus nur sagen, Max, ich wünsche dir ganz viel Glück dabei. Eigentlich wünsche ich dir Erfolg, weil Glück, du bist da viel zu sehr, ich sag mal, bewusst dahinter, dass du Glück, glaube ich, nicht brauchst. Aber ich wünsche dir ganz viel Erfolg, dass es auch ein erfolgreiches, ein großes Projekt ist. Dass es ein Projekt wird in seiner Wahrnehmung. Und ja, ich freue mich, dass ich mal die Gelegenheit hatte, eine Sendung zu moderieren im Rasenfunk.
Du hast das auch so gut gemacht, dass ich mir das einfach vorstellen könnte.
Ja, ich hab's befürchtet.
Sechs Jahre hat's gedauert. Wir haben vor kurzem unseren sechsten Geburtstag gefeiert. Herzlichen Glückwunsch nachträglich.
Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch nachträglich, irre, irre. Und der eigentliche Geburtstag ist ja sogar früher, denn das, was wir als Geburtstag feiern, ist ja immer das Erscheinungsdatum der ersten Folge. Aber ich denke, du erinnerst dich auch noch an die langen Telefonate und Treffen, die wir vorher hatten, bis dann mal alles stand, bis wir den Namen gefunden hatten.
Ich erinnere mich vor allem noch an das erste Gespräch beim TP MoC, und das war bestimmt zwei Jahre, bevor es eigentlich losging. Insofern, der eigentliche Geburtstag ist wahrscheinlich tatsächlich noch ein bisschen früher.
Aber auf jeden Fall.
Dann machen wir das Projekt nicht älter als es ist.
Ne, ne, sechs Jahre reicht auch. Ist ja auch schon lang genug. Ja, danke dir. Ich freue mich über Rückmeldungen der Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie sie es finden. Und dann gucken wir einfach mal, wo das uns alle hingeführt haben wird, dieses Projekt.
Genau. Und euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und Max, haben wir ein Outro?
Wir haben ein Outro. Ich habe schon gerade panisch versucht, das anzumachen. Es ist mir zu spät eingefallen. Es läuft jetzt langsam im leisen Soundbett ein.
Ist ja alles ein bisschen improvisiert heute. Insofern kann auch das Outro ein bisschen improvisiert sein. Okay, also wie gesagt noch einmal, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und hört alle in 11 Leben, die erste Staffel, rund um das Leben von Uli Hoeneß rein. Bis zum nächsten Mal im Rasenfunk. Bis dann.